[Music]
are your home school kids stuck in a rut
well distance learning can certainly be
difficult for the youngest members of
the household
and finding new ways to keep kids
engaged can be a challenge for all
involved but
there are ways to get kids excited again
take a look
with millions of kids still doing remote
learning finding ways to keep them
actively involved and excited is not an
easy task
one option for students to explore could
be learning a new language
this gives students a great chance to be
inspired to
discover global cultures and and learn
some lifelong skills that they can use
for their job or
maybe even earn college credit it's also
fun to look for something to engage your
kids
and really engage the whole family
lifestyle expert kia malone says
with apps like rosetta stone for
students that make the process both fun
and easy
learning the lifelong skill of language
isn't out of reach
and you can even win a free 12-month
subscription to the online program
now through november 12th you can win a
12-month rosetta stone for students
online subscription
there will be 250 winners chosen and
it's so easy to register
you go to rosetta stone.com contest
simply say why your student deserves a
free
12-month subscription and then check
your inbox they'll email all of the
winners
again visit rosettastone.com contest to
learn more